Hello, my name is Elisa Salinas and I come
from Pennsylvania with the organization at
home.
I like it a lot, especially
because I like to connect with my
community and I feel that the
immigrant community needs a lot of support and well,
I realized that since I was little because I
come  of undocumented parents and I
was even undocumented so I
know what it is to suffer so much not having
papers not having a voice and not having
someone to listen to you
thank God I already found myself there are people
on my way who helped me
oriented and so now I want to
educate myself and undertake more so that I can
be that person who can help other
people to move forward